what's up everybody thanks for coming
back to riffin with Griffin and as usual
I don't really know what the theme song
is gonna be putting it out there and
we'll see if this is gonna be the one
doo-doo-doo-doo dusky / defeated item
doo doo doo de doo buh doo buh doo doo
doo doo doo buh doo buh doo buh doo boo
here's a podcast I rode the road my pawn
to listen note for note
don't worry caching goodbye goodbye
dressed and waiting great offend either
by buna butter baby
[Music]
indeed about GD but presently and
Griffin YouTube I do but a reasonably a
green thing but anybody beauty buddy I'm
so stupid
you know I'm trying to kind of come up
with a theme song I like doing this I
think people that listen like me doing
this but I'm gonna say this if you have
an idea for a theme song and you want to
send it out to me so send that [ __ ] out
to me you know what to send me an email
like hey I'm gonna make you a theme so
here it is and then I'll put some lyrics
on it and and then we'll see which one
is the best cuz a lot of people have
been sending me like messages Twitter
Instagram and they're like you owe me I
can make you a song so stop talking
about it just make me a song dammit
I'll try it but anyways thanks for
coming back to riff room with Griffin
everybody I really I really appreciate
it this is episode 6 of different with
Griffin this is right before
Thanksgiving so Happy Thanksgiving
I hope you all had a good Thanksgiving
hope you're not too fat you know don't
lose don't you know
then when the next holiday is gonna be
like for New Year's and Christmas so
that's one will make all our resolutions
and lose all the weight from the
holidays but I hope you had a good
holidays I appreciate once again
everybody that is subscribing and
listening I really do appreciate it but
anyways this is episode 6 officially we
just had episode 5 this is episode 6
I'm always messed up with the numbers
but I'm pretty sure this is episode 6
and what I wanted to talk about this
time is everybody keeps asking me about
I'm dying up here everybody's like yo
you know I'm diner P was so great it was
my favorite show and I just I totally
appreciate all of that energy and
everybody that loved I'm dying up here
and so just podcast is about how I feel
about you know the two seasons of I'm
dying up here and what I think about the
show being canceled and yes if you
didn't know the show is cancelled
I might Ravel all over the country now
and I like I see a lot of old
people who are like I'm saying not
Millennials I'm saying I pin you know
these these are people that grew up in
the 70s people that are loved the 70s
it's a it's an older crowd you know you
have Showtime that means you have money
so those people I appreciate all those
fans and those people are always
disappointed when I tell them this show
is cancelled but I gotta say I love all
the love people give me for I'm dying up
here it's just like it was such a
rewarding experience I really enjoyed it
I loved it I loved doing that show you
know coming off workaholics where I was
Montez and I was like a silly character
and I love Montez Montez was great just
bringing that to life but here we are
with undying appear and I had to like do
some packing you know I had to put on my
acting chops and trust me I didn't think
I could do it it was a lot of stuff on
there I was like oh this is gonna be
hard and but it was very rewarding and
you know I'm sad that the show's gone
really am I had such a good time with
everybody on the show and so I say you
know what let me talk about I'm dying up
here and I've talked about this story a
million times but it's like I was at the
Comedy Store I was like a regular
Tuesday and Adam the manager comes up to
me like yo Jim Carrey's here and I was
so mad I thought he was gonna bump me
and then you know I went up I had a good
set and then like the people that
producers everybody was there auto
producers Michael Aguilar and all those
people were there and they saw me and
they were like yo that's the guy we want
him to be Ralph in like three weeks
later I was I was on the show and the
show was just it I mean it it really was
a tremendous experience so I got my
computer open and I just want to thank
all the people that were on the show you
know we did two seasons and it was it
was two seasons of hair and makeup and
putting on you know putting on a big-ass
afro and like the first season's afro
was not very good if I'm being real the
first season afro was like what is this
didn't look like it was really my hair
so it was weird but and then I think the
other thing too was like if I'm being
rude 100 about it you know I'm mixed
race
I'm very mixed nobody knows who I am
y'all looking at me like is that Drake's
father you know you're not sure if you
should call immigration or Homeland
Security when you look at me so I'm very
mixed I could pass for a lot of
different things so in this particular
show they wanted me to be black you know
and I'm mixed and I am part black I am
I'm part from you know where I am
your Belize Jamaica I have family in
both those places so that's why I have
this look but at the same time I have
like a Eastern European look people
think I'm Jewish some people think I'm
Italian some people think I'm Latino
some people think I'm Middle Eastern so
but in the show they wanted to
accentuate that part and that wasn't the
wig for it so season one I wasn't happy
with the wig the whole wig season one
wigs like what the hell was going on you
know there's people out there like Carla
the make the hair head of hair in season
two she was like uh-uh not with these
wigs you know and I think that was part
of it too is like you know you wanted to
have this 70s
black experience and so you had these
black characters we had Richard Pryor we
had RJ on the show who was playing at
him and he had his little fro then they
had that my little they had my fro and
so they wanted it to be authentic and
I'm not saying that only black people
could do authentic black hair that's not
what I'm saying
but there is something to somebody who
is more familiar with this hair and what
it does and what it looks like and what
does she feel like and and how to work
with it really and so it what it did
make to me it made a difference as
season 2 and I wanted this really great
hair lady as she liked to like made the
hair like my texture so I felt like it
looked way more believable that that was
my hair but it's all part of the acting
right it's just a costume and it's like
you know Superman don't really wear a
cape but you know he has the cape on
does it look natural but I don't know
did he pull it off you know I mean so I
felt like we pulled it off and sees him
won but you know it's like Dave Lebon
head writer Michael Aguilar it's a kid a
producer those two guys with a heart and
soul of
deine appear and of course not Jim
Carrey you know I'm gonna thank him
because a lot of this show came from his
vision his his experience like he lived
in a closet that's why he we had two
characters living in the closet so you
know when I read the script I was like I
said it was very challenging and I was
like oh man can I really pull this off
and you know the 70s and it was like man
you gotta be this comic in the 70s
that's kind of weird because you know
when you're a comic you build your voice
for like eight nine years whatever it is
you get your point of view and then this
is your point of view and then so now
you got to play someone who has lived
that eight nine years and they have
their own point of view which is
different from your point of view so I
think the stand-up kind of suffered but
I don't think stayed like trying to do
stand-up on camera
your fake stand-up it's just hard to do
you know I think we pulled it off in
some areas you know like I thought al
Madrigal was like so good but that's
what they showed it at snippets you know
and he really worked on that stand up
and so they show these little snippets
so that was good but anytime it was like
a long set it just to me came off as
weird because it's not organic like
stand-ups organic you capture something
in the room you know and that's why even
special sometimes a weird you watch a
stand-up special and you'd be like I've
seen that person live and I think
they're much funnier live and then
there's something weird about some weird
happening but the lights with like you
know you know they're doing takes and
cuts and edits and it just loses a
little something so really great
stand-up specials are the ones that can
really capture that live experience so
imagine having like extras and like
cameras on the stage and different
angles and like having to do something
over and over and over again it's really
hard to capture that so you know you
know I don't know if we pulled it off
all the time on the show I think you big
why did the show get canceled that's
like the thing well not enough people
were watching the show I mean obviously
I think if more people were watching the
show we'd still be on the air right now
so for all you people that loved this
show I wish you would have told a
hundred of your favorite friends and
maybe we'd still be on the air
I think there was some stuff like even
behind the scenes I think I think this
is my personal opinion and I'm just
putting it out there I don't give a [ __ ]
I think they Showtime wanted a comedy
and we delivered a drama I think there
was some kind of disconnect with what
kind of show that we were supposed to
deliver or maybe the expectations that
they had I mean if you were getting into
business with Jim Carrey and you say hey
Jim I want to make a show with Jim
Carrey
maybe you think oh this is gonna be a
wacky comedy maybe this is like not
knowing that he's at a different stage
in his life right now artistically that
he wants to put out something completely
different and as what he did goes
there's two shows now I'm dying up here
and kidding who are I'm not kidding they
ain't comedies you know so that might
have been a disconnect right there so I
think that you know I don't know if we
had the full support of the network
after season one kind of tanked
look this would be real you know so
that's the first thing I think to happen
to why we got canceled and to like
season one I just think season one was
like we went up after twin peaks' twin
Pete I don't know if you guys watched
twin peaks' but the only thing that
should come on after Twin Peaks is the
national anthem and the American flag
and then the station should go blank
like they used to do in the old days so
you could figure out what the hell did
you just witness what did you just watch
you had to think about things like after
I watched Twin Peaks in in like a six
minute outro with a fly on the screen
like I wasn't ready to watch something
like melodramatic
you know drama comedy some drama tea
after that so I thought that was a huge
mistake
I thought they buried us with that I
mean I wish we would have come after the
shameless put us on after shameless
that's their number one show put us on
after that it's like a dark dark comedy
then you have our little dark comedy but
you know that's just me I thought that
the posters I didn't know what the hell
that was like we had this dead guy on
the thing that was like too on-the-nose
I'm dying up here then somebody's dead
then you see the poster and you're like
what is this about what is this show
about I don't know what it's about
who is that what's going on is it a
documentary is it a comedy is it a drama
it what is it so I don't think we made
our message clear and I think we
suffered because of that but we got our
groove in season 1 though season 1 you
guys don't know what was happened in
season 1
you know first before I even talk about
the seasons let me just talk about
everybody that was on the show you know
what I mean so like you know Melissa Leo
starting with the Great and Powerful
Melissa Leo she was she was something
else you know she's an Oscar winner and
she's a very much an artist in the full
sense of the word like if you if you're
a person that's an actor and you think
acting is an art you know how can when
you watch like the award shows and you
see like Viola Davis like talk about
acting in that kind of like artsy fartsy
way that is melissa leo in a nutshell
she definitely was artsy fartsy she
definitely was like wanted to become
this character and blessin necessarily a
nice person the character and she
embodied that and she became that and
she was bossy and like you know she
taught me a lot of things she would come
sneak up behind me on the makeup chair
and be like Eric I don't think you
should do it like that you know she
would just give me little tips and
things cuz she felt that I was open to
hearing her advice but she was something
else man I remember there's time we were
it was me Andrew Santino and el mágico
it was like the first time we're
shooting together and we're sitting here
in the hallway discussing the scene and
in there rehearsing literally like in it
like we're not disturbing anybody I
didn't know where she comes up like a
ninja like don't talk doing rehearsal I
looked at these dudes they looked at me
cuz I'm like this is three grown-ass men
we three grown-ass men yo check yourself
like check yourself before you wreck
yourself okay I don't care what awards
you've won that's just kind of attitude
that the three of us had but we know how
to deal with that as comics you know we
know we know how to deal with you know
with difficult personalities and so I
think that's why it overall worked
that's why I think the cast was so close
but Melissa Leo was just great there was
times that you know she might have
flipped out and then thin it's action
and then she does it and you're like god
damn just [ __ ] can't
act she is she was brilliant you know
and then we had the Great and Powerful
ari Graynor re she was fantastic was you
know she was the girl you know what I
mean I mean we were representing the 70s
and I know Hollywood right now is on
this multiracial we have to have a lot
of women and but it wasn't like that in
the 70s oh how I think that was another
thing working against us by the way is
what was going on in society so we got
to me to movement and we got all this
stuff going on then we had this
male-dominated show from the 70s because
that's how it was you know what I mean
so I think that they like they centered
on like well we have to pump up Ari and
Melissa we had to make sure that there
is front and center and I don't know if
that was service to show you know to its
best of its ability but no knock on them
you know I just think it's like the
combination of the times and everything
that was going on you know but Ari was
great you know she played Cassie and she
had this great like she really worked on
the stand-up she's never done stand-up
before so she went to open mics and she
was like trying to like she wanted it to
be authentic and real and she really put
herself into it and I thought the the
pilot of this show when she has her
little breakdown onstage I thought it
was very beautiful
it was just moving and beautiful and I
thought that was a good set to tone for
the show but that thing again another
problem with the show was that we didn't
know that it was gonna I don't think
there was people on the show that didn't
realize that this was an ensemble it
just wasn't gonna be like oh this is
gonna be the Melissa Leo show or the ari
Graynor show or the Eric Griffin show it
was this was not that this was an
ensemble from the beginning so but they
didn't make that clear we did the pilot
and you were like okay you know because
the pilot was all about Cassie you know
and then so then the second episode
you're like what happened all that
because they now that you know what they
want where they want it to go but I
don't think that was made clear so and
then there's good old Michael angry on
oh I never say his name right is it our
gang Angora no I always say angry on oh
but does nothing his anger on oh I don't
know I love Mike is one month
people in the whole wide world I'm
actually gonna have Mike on the podcast
he's gonna be one of my first guests but
he was great he was one of the guys that
came from Boston and Mike's great he's
been in like he's been in like so many
great movies I want it I want to look it
I'm gonna have let me look up someone
like stuff here cuz I got his IMDB open
right now too cuz you know he was in the
Forbidden Kingdom I didn't remember he
was in the freakin Forbidden Kingdom you
know what I'm gonna talk about this cuz
I am gonna have him on the podcast and
I'm gonna talk about this stuff but he
was in forgetting Forbidden Kingdom
skyhigh almost famous he was in so many
great movies and he's really got some
great stories so look out for that I am
gonna have him on here but Mike was just
he was a pleasure to work with and we
became really close that's the same
thing with Clark Duke it's funny Clark
Duke and him they were the guys that
came from Boston to me the show should
have been about those guys coming from
Boston it should have been about them
they cuz the pilot popped when we went
to Boston and saw them and then they
came to LA that's whether the show
should have been about you know and then
I'm always confident my podcast and I'm
always talking about me talking on my
part on my podcast and then there was
you know so hymning so Clark Duke and
and Mike they were like those great
Boston guys and Clark was great and
there's funny cuz I had worked with
Clark like a few months before we did
the pilot on workaholics we did a
workaholics episode together and he was
like oh I'm gonna be on that show he was
growing his hair out and I was like oh
man that's gonna be so great so that was
good and then of course we had Sebastian
Stan let me just talk about Sebastian
Stan so Sebastian is like it's funny
that when you look on Instagram you look
up I'm dying up here it's still all
about Sebastian Stan this [ __ ]
was there one episode but he's such a
gorgeous hunky guy that he's associated
with our show off of one episode he was
the comic that died in the show and
personally to me like I didn't care
about it I didn't care about his
character I just didn't you know I like
I said the show popped when the two guys
came from Boston and I really enjoyed
that but Sebastian was great and he was
he's another artsy guy by the way just
artsy fartsy and he was cool but you
know but the main cast you know we had
Mike and Clark they do the guys from
Boston love those guys to this day and
then RJ RJ Siler RJ is the coolest
[ __ ] he was in Power Rangers
he's just man I had such a great
chemistry with him I love all my scenes
with him and it just was like it was so
moving
he just is such a cool kid to work with
you got good head on his shoulders comes
from a good family
I'm having him on the podcast too so I
don't want to talk about him too much
and then my main man Andrew Santino you
know what's so funny about Andrew and I
is that we would always I always see him
at the same auditions right we couldn't
cuz he's just weird redhead you know the
red heads are weird even though he's a
handsome alpha male guy it's like you
you know he still went out for weirdo
roles so I would be there too
it would be like I'd be like huh here's
this [ __ ] again you know so
we're always going out for some of the
same parts this was the first time we
like were going for different parts for
the same show so when I walked into the
test and I saw him we were like oh you
know it was like so fun and we were the
only ones like you know talking to other
guys in the room were just like nervous
as [ __ ] they were just like you know you
know trying to get your things right I
want to get on a book just part and him
and I were just like whatever how you
doing man just talking about the roles
and just like being like this is gonna
be the funnest time ever I hope we get
this you know turns out we both booked
it so that was cool and then there's al
Madrigal love out al is he's I was a
comedy Sheriff you know al magic he's
got a great special shrimpin a tease you
got to watch that he was on a daily show
he just punch of little movie is he you
probably if you don't know him by name
recognition when you see me gonna be
like oh that guy but Al's great he was
elected the grandpa on the set you know
I was like like he's the comedy Sheriff
like if that's why it's so funny cause I
was so pretentious that he loved being
this hacky Mexican comic on the show
because he would never do that kind of
material on stage but he loved doing
that he was he was like I get it I you
know he just was like oh man this is so
fun just to say like you know tacos and
whatever he was doing but
it was like a blessing to have on the
shown he was in the writers room first
season so he had a little bit of
gravitas to the stand-up stuff so he was
fighting for us in the writers room
about like you know
well the comics wouldn't do this the
comics wouldn't do that and you know it
was good to have him there and then Jake
Lacey came on a show I love Jake
Jake is one of the coolest most
down-to-earth dudes he was in I gotta
look up Jake stuff cuz Jake lives in New
York so I don't know if I could have him
on the podcast so I have to talk about
Jake properly but he was just in rampage
and he died in ramp he was the bad guy
in rampage he died but he was in what's
that movie Sloan he was like he played a
hooker in a movie he just done like a
lot of great stuff man
he was in an office you know so he's
done comedy but he's an artsy fartsy one
- Jake is definitely like he can you
could sit and talk about acting with
Jake for hours and he will give you like
he'll give you the realness and you'll
just be fascinated by having a
conversation with him you know he really
took it seriously and then everything
has to mean something an important him
and Cassie they had a lot of I used to
tease them because their scenes would go
on forever shooting there seems to be
like eight hours seen them sitting on a
diving board that [ __ ] took forever to
film because they are that into it
they're that professional and like you
know they just needed it to be perfect
so who else we got there then there was
Jon Daly who is like the most hilarious
dude John Daly is just a breath of fresh
air on a set you know he had he was
Arnie you know he had the great hair you
know he just he's like gold he's a scene
stealer that [ __ ] but but John
Daly look him up he's he's freaking
awesome
and then Steven Guarino who is he so he
was so good in season 1 then I you know
and and then a they cut him out of the
show and I still don't get it I still
don't get it like history he was the one
he went and he decided he needed a quick
comedy or scale back so he can be a dad
and take care of his wife and get a real
job which is a real struggle that a lot
of comics have to deal with there comes
a time when you're like doing comedy and
you're like can I do this is this is
this a pipe dream can i really make it
maybe I am good enough to make it but
life gets in the way and that was just a
great story and I don't know why the
[ __ ] they took that off I mean it pisses
me off like it's like people that like
they're people that like just sign
cheques think that they know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about and that was
just a something that makes me man now
that was a stupid decision to take him
off the show frickin stupid then we had
ginger ginger Gonzaga she's actually on
kiddin right now she's the crazy one on
kiddin and you know ginger was great she
was the first Bush she had she had to
put the bushy thing on you know cuz in
the seventies the [ __ ] was bushy you
know we saw her booty a lot on the show
and she was just she just went for it
you know but she was like a great you
know she was like Arnie's girlfriend and
Clint and and Clark's girlfriend and you
know she just was a she's a real she's a
funny lady you know it's like Annie I'm
glad she's winning I'm glad she's out
there on that other show because she
deserves that
and then Rick Overton was on the show oh
my god wakes up legend and he was just
so fun to be around and then we had
early eco you know he's he won he was on
roast battle you know he's the weird
Jewish guy with the glasses and he
always he was just a character but he
was playing at a horrible hack comic
he's always like this kind of hit home
but now Earl's funny
then there was Joel Joel Dutton you know
he was what he played what did he play
he was Gabe so he was like the Jewish
comic you know he was great doing then
we had Dom Barrera another legend the
ethic they killed him on the show he
didn't like that I'm gonna tell you that
he didn't like that [ __ ] Brad Garrett
Brad Garrett for this season the season
2 was phenomenal just he was just and
he's such a great storyteller he
sometimes we sittin in between scenes
and he just went he could just sit on a
lounge chair and just tell stories about
the old days and he was a breath of
fresh air and it sucks did his show got
canceled because I feel like he did some
Emmy worthy [ __ ] and now cuz nobody's
gonna vote for a show that's been
canceled but he did some Emmy worthy
[ __ ] and it sucks that we got cancelled
because now he's not gonna get his due
so that's another reason why I'm doing
this right now
and Scioscia oh man she came on she
played dawn she she was on Mindy project
you know she was a nurse on Mindy
project so she came in to play this sort
of bisexual black comic and you know
dealing with being a lesbian in the 70s
and doing with her dealing with her
comedies so she came on she was a great
addition to the show so that was great
and Stefania oh man she was awesome too
she played Goldie's daughter you know
she was great obba oh man oh you know
you got to go to our IMDB page and look
up all these people I mean I'm not
getting it everybody because it's the
list it just goes on and on and on and
on and on but you know I hit up most of
the main the main guys on the show the
main the main people and you know I just
Sarah hey she was another one I got a
say I got a say what's up to Sarah Sarah
she was great Sarah was freaking awesome
on flesh and bone on Starz another show
that a network canceled without really
giving it its due but she got nominated
for a Golden Globe I mean she was just
phenomenal on that show and she came on
our show and just added so get so many
if you go to IMDB and you go down that
list it's a lot of great [ __ ]
on that list alright so anyways thus the
cast then we go into season one so we
had Jonathan Levon Jonathan is just
great director he directs the pilot we
had this the great DP you know so we had
this lighting and everything looks
delicious and then you know that the
pilot is great was a really great pilot
it really captures the heart and soul of
what you wanted to show to be and then
we had to wait months and months and
months and months and months and then we
shoot episode two different director
different DP different look different
feel so
that's why I feel like we kind of
floundered a little bit like the first
two three four episodes of season one we
didn't know who we were we didn't know
what was going on yet I had that scene
where I had to beat the guy up and in
bathroom and even I was thinking to
myself I beat this guy up and then this
is the 70s so I beat this drunk white
guy up and then no cops come to get me
how is that even handled but we kind of
glossed over that it's that kind of
stuff but it's like you're talking about
so many characters a small riders room
because there's not a big budget and
they have to service all these people I
mean I commend them on the work that
they did I mean Dave labott I mean I
just come in the guy you know and he was
sick he you know he has a kidney thing
and he was like he had to go to the
hospital and you know he still was like
riding and taking care of business and
and Mike you know he was just the heart
and soul my guy Goulart the producer he
was like the showrunner and he was like
Owen said having to deal with all these
egos and personalities can you imagine
having like all these comics and the
nice like artsy actors all in one place
trying to manage that just know [ __ ] it
was like Pat Riley out there dealing
with all this so you know so I said says
you know episode 2 3 and know what the
show was about four and then Episode
five was this episode where I had to be
to do this like my Vietnam guy you know
came you know and Jaco
Jaco Sims plays my buddy from Vietnam
and he did an excellent job you know
he's on a great show now I'm some doctor
show I wish I could say the name of I'm
gonna have him on - I'm gonna have
Jacque go on to them I'll talk to him so
I had to do this Vietnam thing and I was
really nervous about it you know I was
like oh man am I gonna pull this off
because part of the part of my
apprehension about doing I'm dying
appear was that it was about the comedy
store this place it's like a church it's
like I had such reverence for the place
and and you know you do a show sort of
about the place sort of about this era
that built this whole thing up and then
you got to walk these hallways if you do
in a [ __ ] show you walk in these
hallways and you and you know we people
don't talk [ __ ] so I was really
surprised about how many of the comics
and my colleagues who were like yo man
you did a good job or I really like to
show I think that to me was the kiss of
death when comics like something
[ __ ] ain't gonna be good I think that
was the reason why we need you I needed
to come was to be like I don't like this
and then regular people being like I
really love this I think if I had to you
know I don't know if I had to do it all
again I think I still do want it to be
the same but you know that was the thing
I just didn't want to walk through the
halls and people think that I didn't I
couldn't act or I didn't do a good job
you know it was really important to me
you know I saw you know really worked on
that stuff and we did that and that's
what I think the show took off episode
fives when we got Jake Lacey on the show
and then also I think we settled into
who the DP was gonna be because in
season one we had like three or four
different directors of picked direct
director of picture you know that's the
person in charge of every shot and like
you know how much smoke is gonna be in
the room and that was another thing we
had all this frickin smoke and I had to
smoke on the show that was a [ __ ]
nightmare those herbal cigarettes you
think cigarettes are bad try herbal
cigarettes those shits suck so we did
season one we didn't get the ratings
that we thought we were gonna get we did
it just didn't take off it just didn't
you know and I know there's people out
there they're like I can't believe this
show was canceled and neither can i but
at the same time I gotta be real if you
make a show where half the critics are
trashing us and and people aren't
watching the show gift that you have to
ask you some what did is did we make a
good show I don't know if that's what
you're gonna don't want you're gonna go
on audience and critics which seems
silly when you say it out loud but hey
it's you know what it reminds me of it's
like the music business and I remember
Prince
the rest is r.i.p Prince but I remember
when he changed his name and he was on
BTS they had this news program and
Prince was on there talking about why he
changed his name cuz it was to get out
of his contract and he was saying like
he just didn't want to be in the music
business I'll never forget this cuz he
was saying like hey I just put out an
album it was like I remember the crystal
ball album he said I put the album out I
sold a hundred thousand copies of it for
$50 that's five million dollars he was
like is that a failure and I thought
about that I was like oh [ __ ] ain't a
failure it's not a failure at all but in
terms of the music business they might
consider
a failure because they need you to sell
10 million records or whatever their
thing is and he was like
direct-to-consumer
so I'm saying I think we're in the same
kind of boat we put off this really
artsy project and only like 200,000
people watched it does that mean it was
bad
no it just didn't catch on with a lot of
people and I think part of that problem
was what we did we I'm talking we those
producers show time not advertising the
thing properly not really it just yeah
we just dropped the ball on that and I
think that's why I didn't catch on you
know but you can still watch it you know
and then season two like I said when we
added like Brad Garrett and all the
people that came on the show I think
season 2 was I am proud of the work that
we did I'm very sad that the show is off
the air and I just wanted to put this
podcast out just say to people thank you
for everybody that watched I'm dying up
here and who are continuing to watch I'm
gone I'm here and will continue to watch
it in the future
we made 20 episodes so go out and watch
it you know it's 20 that's 20 hours we
made 20 hours that would be four seasons
of a half-hour show right if you think
about it like that and I'm proud of it I
really am and I think it's it's good TV
I wish we would still keep going but at
the same time I'm like you know what I'm
not sitting here like we made some [ __ ]
no we made some good stuff we make some
good TV so I want you to go out and
watch the Don up here if you get a
chance and so this is really just a
thank you
so thank you to the fans as a thank you
to all the cast all the crew makeup
Showtime - you know hey we made some
mistakes but Showtime took a chance it
is a business it was an expensive show
to make so it's like we're going like yo
nobody watched the show and we got bad
reviews hey you want can you spend fifty
million dollars again so I totally get
you know that them game like you know
it's like you buy a house for 10 million
dollars and then it's not the house you
want or the Foundation's a little messed
up and then you turn around and go watch
just buy another ten million dollar
house it don't work like that sometimes
she can't be fixed and you gotta
bulldoze it or sell it off and get your
money back so I get it I'm not I'm not
completely upset they're not all to
blame you know and we did what we did
like I say I'm proud of the show and I'm
I'm glad you guys are listening to me
now I'm glad you guys are still watching
it the people that are watching it and
you know go out and support all the
people that you've seen from the show
and on their other things but anyways
this is Eric Griffin episode 6 riffing
with gone and I hope you had a good
holiday and look for me again in another
week and I appreciate you
[Music]